bonjour à tous on va parler de l'ipad
gros x l'ipad pro 2018 qui pourrait
sortir cette année et on va regarder ça
maintenant 2018 devrait être une bonne
année pour apple
il faut savoir que 4ème trimestre 2010
est a été excellent apple a battu ses
records en termes de chiffre d'affaires
par contre les ventes d iphone n'ont pas
été super bon à la différence
les ipad se porte plutôt bien
à savoir que le marché des tablettes est
assez morose baisse depuis quelques
temps apple est le seul à tirer son
épingle du jeu avec une croissance de
plus de 3%
il a une leader au niveau de la vente
mondiales de tablettes apple à lui seul
comptabilise 26 6% de parts de marché
amazon 15 6%
samsung 14,1 pour cent waouh et 7,1 pour
cent
lenovo 6,2 les agents parlent pas l'ipad
est donc la tablette la plus vendue au
monde donc ça paraît logique qu'apple
est redessinée cette tablette du moins
l'ipad pro vu les nouvelles
spécifications qu'on peut retrouver sur
son iphone 10 montrer donc retrouver un
design très proche de celui de l'iphone
10 un design nouvelle génération celui
qu'on va retrouver dans les iphone de
cette année bon les iphone vous en ai
déjà parlé
si vous voulez en savoir plus je vous
invite à aller voir cette vidéo dans
lequel je vous parle effectivement des
tendances des rumeurs des infos des
fuites par rapport aux iphone de 2018 il
paraîtrait logique que cet ipad et faith
a dit c'est super normal l'ipad procès
le haut de gamme des ipad c'est celui
qui se destine à ceux qui ont le plus de
besoin aux professionnels avec votre
paintsil pour voir dessiner sur votre
écran
donc c'est tout à fait normal qu'ils
bénéficient des nouvelles et dernières
technologies les plus innovantes d'apple
alors qu'il y fasse elle dit
disparition du bouton home si on aime
bouton home qui disparaît il est très
logique que les petites bordure
s'amincissent et qui dit bordure a ainsi
dit nouveau design dit probablement un
écran toujours 10 5 pouces mais avec un
châssis réduit maintenant il ya un point
d'interrogation au niveau du design
il est évident on va avoir un écran plus
grand des bords plus petits faith heidi
donc forcément une caméra trop d'eps
aura-t-on l'encoche comme sur l'iphone
dise voilà il ya deux écoles il ya d'un
côté ceux qui pensent qu'ils auront à
bord un peu plus grands qui du coup
intégrera la caméra troudet pts sur le
haut et il ya ceux qui pensent au
contraire que l'écran prendra beaucoup
de place avec la présence de la caméra
trou d'air sur le haut dont la fameuse
encoches d'ailleurs dit moi vous ce que
vous espérez est ce que vous voudriez
que cet ipad pro 2010 8 et 7 ans coche
alors est ce que vous seriez prêts à
avoir des bords un peu plus large
mais la voir disparaître la barre en
tout cas fondu dans le bar en bois m'est
témoin tous ces commentaires qui ni fax
heidi disparition du bouton home dit
forcément des nouveaux gestes dont
contraire trouvé effectivement les
nouveaux gestes en tout cas ce qu'on
retrouve dans l'iphone bis donc tous les
possesseurs d'un ipad vont devoir un
petit peu réapprendre les différents
gestes les différents mouvements
alors rassurez vous sur l'iphone disent
ça se fait c'est très facile
voudriez y arriver nouvelle navigation
donc quelque part aussi nouvel os est ce
qu'on va garder un os 11 optimisé pour
ce nouvel ipad ou alors carrément avoir
l'oeil os 12
je pense plutôt qu'on ira sur l'ios 12
je pense que cet ipad pro 2018 sera
présente et où d'habitude avait lui
aussi en juin de l'année prochaine et
qu'en même temps il y aura une
présentation du nouvel os ios 12 qui
sera complètement optimisé pour ce
produit qui permettra effectivement
d'avoir de meilleures performances
une meilleure utilisation il devrait
aussi y avoir un nouveau pencil un
nouveau stylet pour pouvoir aller plus
loin pour avoir des nouveaux mouvements
faire des choses encore plus fine au
niveau de vos dessins et au niveau
d'autres écritures donc vraiment voir
tout un univers qui sera optimisé pour
ce produit de 2018 la prédiction de la
cannelle à trous d'eps a été faite par
mais une psycho qui est l'analyste star
de cash et securities
alors j'en ai déjà parlé mills inc au
fait toujours des prédictions qui
s'avère assez juste et de toute façon ça
paraîtrait logique dès maintenant tous
les produits à genk sortiront apple
devant
voir la caméra prodex il est plus
possible aujourd'hui de sortir un
nouveau produit qui va coûter cher du
haut de gamme avec un bouton home le
borderless c'est vraiment la tendance
qui s'est accentuée qui s'est imposée en
il est très clair qu'en 2018 on va
continuer là-dessus d'ailleurs il ya une
autre info qui est sortie qui était
fouiner dans le code d'ios
11.3 pour trouver une mention très
intéressante
il est écrit ipad moderne alors ça ne
vous parle probablement pas il faut
savoir qu'avant que l'iphone dix sortes
il avait déjà été remarqué dans le code
la mention d'iphone moderne donc iphone
moderne ipad moderne fait vraiment
référence à cette nouvelle génération
est ce qu'on va retrouver un ipad 10
ipad pro 2018 même si on connaît pas
aujourd'hui la dénomination exacte
en tout cas on va très bien qu'on se
profile vers un produit avec flybe avec
un écran qui occupe la quasi totalité de
la face avant
côté puissance ont retrouvé la puce à
11x à huit coeurs gravés en 7 nanomètres
et fabriqué pour apple par tsmc la carte
graphique devrait aussi complètement
personnalisé pour apple un produit plus
puissant qui vous permettra
effectivement d'optimiser d'aller plus
loin au niveau de votre travail
que ce soit pour utilisation
professionnelle ou familiale l'ipad pro
il devra envoyer du bois
il reste un doute en suspens pour
l'écran je vous parle effectivement d'un
écran 10 2 5 pouces dans un châssis
beaucoup plus petit mais a priori on
resterait sur du lcd pas du hall est
cette fois ci un peu le regret je trouve
ça génial qu'apple puisse proposer en
2018 sur son ipad pro un très bel écran
oled mais a priori cette année il faudra
encore se contenter d'un écran lcd
côté photo on devrait retrouver à
l'arrière sensiblement les mêmes
appareils photos que ceux présents sans
l'iphone 10,2 capteur 12 mégapixels à
l'avant un seul capteur probablement un
8 mégapixels
bien évidemment quelques années à
chelsea vous pourrez avoir le mode
portrait je ne pense pas qu'on aurait de
la recharge à induction sur ipad pour
alors je peux me planter mais pour
pouvoir effectivement recharger un ehpad
pro par induction il vous faut une borne
quand même assez conséquente il ya le
air power qui sort cette année mais le
air power est censé pouvoir connecter
trois objets différents un iphone 10
derrière pod et la world series 3 ça me
semblerait très compliqué de pouvoir
effectivement l'utiliser entièrement que
pour votre ipad pro la recherche doit
donc rester un petit peu plus
conventionnel avec le point avec nous
mais néanmoins rassurez vous on devrait
avoir une batterie toujours des
puissantes pour absorber la pluie
sens de la puce à 11x quand est-ce
qu'ils devraient sortir normalement il
paraîtrait très logique et sont annoncés
aux joints aux d'abeilles ou d'abeille
ou dit si ça me semblerait très bizarre
qu'il soit annoncé avant aussi
surprenant qu'il le soit après puisqu'en
septembre c'est toujours la date
d'annoncé des iphone si apple respecte
son calendrier
il devrait annoncer en juin le nouvel os
le nouvel ipad probablement d'autres
objets revue revisité peut-être l'apple
tv
on peut imaginer aussi cette année voire
une nouvelle watch la watch series 4
avec un nouveau design bord à bord donc
tout ça on en parlera un peu plus tard
quoi qu'il en soit c'est un produit qui
risque de coûter un petit peu cher je
peux pas me prononcer sur leur ai tout
de suite mais quoiqu'il se passe il sera
forcément plus cher que l'ipad pro au
catalogue actuel d'apple
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez est
ce que vous pensez que sa taille pas de
pros s'appellera ipad prod et mes
dix-huit ipad pro 10 marques qui m'a
tout sans commentaire est ce qu'il
pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que vous avez déjà un ipad pro
est ce que ce modèle là vous paraît
intéressant mark et moi tout ça comme
d'habitude vous invite à me laisser des
jolies pousse à rester connectés parce
qu'on va parler toujours plus toujours
mieux de high tech
il ya énormément de choses à venir
énormément de surprises d'ici quelques
jours je vais aller au mwc à barcelone
pour voir un peu les nouvelles annonces
de la téléphonie mobile et des tablettes
donc rester vraiment avec moi parce que
vous allez voir il va y avoir énormément
de choses super passionnante des tests à
venir des zones boxing des infos des
extraits d actu on n'en peut plus merci
beaucoup
à très bientôt sur les sages et d'ici là
vous embrasse change
[Musique]